MARIA: WELCOME BACK WE’VE GOT
NEW FOX NEWS POLLS RELEASED THIS
MORNING AND IT SHOWS
CORONAVIRUS IS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE FOR VOTERS HEADING INTO
THE 2020 ELECTION MORE THAN HALF
DISAPPROVE OF HOW THE PRESIDENT
IS HANDLED WITH THIS PANDEMIC
I’M JOINED RIGHT NOW BY THE
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
MARK MEADOWS LEADING THE
ADMINISTRATION THROUGH THIS
CRISIS AND MARK IT IS GOOD
TO HAVE YOU THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US FIRST OFF WHAT
CAN YOU SAY TO YOUR CRITICS WHO
SAY THE PRESIDENT HAS FALLEN
SHORT IN HIS RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC?
>> WELL OBVIOUSLY, ANYTIME THAT
WE GET FACED WITH SOMETHING THAT
IS NEW AND UNUSUAL, YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE TO ENGAGE AND SO THIS CAME
FROM CHINA IN THE LAST FOUR OR
FIVE MONTHS.
WE’VE BEEN HAVING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO PROVIDE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT, VENTILATOR
S, MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE HOSPITAL BEDS AND I CAN
TELL YOU AS WE LOOK FORWARD
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT WE’RE WORKING ON TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
THERAPEUTICS, EVEN AS RECENT
AS THIS MORNING SHIPMENTS GOING
TO FLORIDA AND INDIANA AND OTHER
PLACES TO MAKE SURE THAT SOME OF
THE TREATMENTS THAT ARE NEEDED
IN THESE CRITICAL AREAS ARE
ACTUALLY HAPPENING AND I ALSO
CAN TELL YOU THAT IT’S A 24/7
AROUND THE CLOCK KIND OF
WORK.
I WAS ON THE PHONE WITH THE
PRESIDENT THIS MORNING AS WE
WERE WORKING ON SOME OF THE
RESPONSES.
YOU’LL SEE SOME NEW INITIATIVES
COMING OUT THIS WEEK AS THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT ONLY
LEADING BUT WILL CONTINUE TO
LEAD AND STEP UNIN A NUMBER OF
FRONTS.
ONE THAT YOU JUST MENTIONED
EARLIER MARIA IS ABOUT OUR
SCHOOLS.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO OPEN OUR
SCHOOLS AND MAKE SURE THAT MOMS
AND DADS DON’T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF OUR CHILDREN
THEY’RE GOING BACK-TO-SCHOOLS
AND SO THERE WILL BE OVER
$70 BILLION THAT THIS PRESIDENT
HAS ALREADY AUTHORIZED TO WORK
WITH CONGRESS TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE NOT ONLY KEEP THE
CLASSROOMS SAFE BUT THE
TEACHERS SAFE AND STUDENTS
SAFE AND YOU’LL SEE A VERY BROAD
FIVE-TO-SIX POINTS IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE WILL BE DOING IN TERMS
OF MAKING SURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS
ARE SAFE.
MARIA: THAT’S REALLY IMPORTANT,
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO LIVE WITH THIS FOR A LITTLE
WHILE, BEFORE WE GET THE
INNOVATION FROM OUR
PHARMA SECTOR AND A VACCINE.
TELL ME WHAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IN ANOTHER RELIEF
PACKAGE, MARK.
WHERE ARE WE IN TERMS OF THE
RELIEF AND THE IMPACT ON THE
ECONOMY AND PEOPLE’S
LIVELIHOODS?
>> WELL THERE’S THE DISCUSSIONS
HAVE JUST STARTED OVER THE LAST
WEEK OR  SO.
WE’VE BEEN HAVING A NUMBER OF
INTERNAL DISCUSSIONS OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS, BUT
AS WE’VE STARTED TO ENGAGE WITH
OUR SENATE AND HOUSE COLLEAGUES
UP ON CAPITOL HILL, THOSE WILL
START IN EARNEST STARTING
TOMORROW, MONDAY I KNOW THAT
LEADER MCCONNELL AND LEADER
MCCARTHY WILL BE COMING INTO
MEET WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
STEVEN MNUCHIN WHOSE LEADING IT
FROM OUR SIDE TO ACTUALLY START
TO FINE TUNE IT SO I’D SEE
THERE’S THREE DIFFERENT
AREAS THAT WE’RE GOING TO MAKE
SURE OF, THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
EXPEDITE NOT ONLY THE WARP SPEED
AS IT RELATES TO THE TREATMENTS
THAT WE HAVE, WHETHER IT BE
THERAPEUTICS OR  VACCINES, BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE KEEP PEOPLE EMPLOYED.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ECONOMY AND
WHERE WE NEED TO GO WITH IT,
WE’RE NOT GOING TO BE SHY ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
PROTECTIONS FOR THE AMERICAN
WORKER AND THOSE THAT EMPLOY
INDIVIDUALS AND SO YOU’RE GOING
TO SEE AN  ADDITIONAL THRUST
THERE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT THAT NEW
PACKAGE WILL BE IN THE TRILLION
DOLLAR RANGE AS WE’VE STARTED TO
LOOK AT IT WHETHER IT’S A
PAYROLL TAX DEDUCTION, WHETHER
IT’S MAKING SURE THAT
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS CONTINUE,
WITHOUT A DISINCENTIVE TO RETURN
TO WORK AND THEN BLUNTLY, WE’RE
LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF AREAS TO
LOOK AT MANUFACTURING, BRINGING
SOME OF THOSE CRITICAL
MANUFACTURING JOBS BACK FROM
OVERSEAS, SO THAT WE’RE NEVER
PUT IN A SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE
TO DEPEND ON FOREIGN COUNTRIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN PROTECT
AMERICANS.
MARIA: AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
TALKED ABOUT THE CRIME ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AS WELL.
IS THERE SOMETHING COMING IN
TERMS OF AN EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
RETURNING LAW AND ORDER TO THIS
COUNTRY?
>> WELL HE’S ALREADY DONE A
COUPLE OF THINGS BUT HE’S
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THIS WEEK
WHAT WE’RE LOOKING AT IS NOT
ONLY LOOKING AT WHAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE CALLED THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER ON STATUES, WHICH HE DID
THAT BUT THAT’S REALLY THE
STATUES ARE ONE THING BUT
IT’S REALLY ABOUT KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFE AND THE
PRESIDENT’S COMMITTED TO DO
THAT.
SOME OF THE UNREST THAT WE SAW
EVEN IN THE LAST MONTH OR  SO
BUT PARTICULARLY LAST NIGHT AND
THE WEEK LEADING UP TO IT IN
PORTLAND, IT’S JUST NOT
ACCEPTABLE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
COMMUNITIES NOT BEING SAFE AND
NOT UPHOLDING THE RULE OF LAW,
SO ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR IS
WEIGHING IN ON THAT WITH
SECRETARY WOLF AND YOU’LL SEE
SOMETHING ROLLED OUT THIS
WEEK AS WE START TO GO IN
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMUNITIES WHETHER IT’S
CHICAGO, OR  PORTLAND, OR
MILWAUKEE, OR  SOME PLACE
ACROSS THE HEARTLAND OF THE
COUNTRY, WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
SAFE.
MARIA: MARK LET ME TURN TO THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
YOU DID SUCH AN  EXCELLENT JOB
WHEN YOU WERE ON THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF ZEROING IN
ON THE ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA
PROBE.
WE NOW KNOW FOR SURE LINDSEY
GRAHAM TOLD US THIS ABOUT A
MONTH AGO ACTUALLY, SO OUR
AUDIENCE WAS AWARE THAT THE FBI
KNEW THAT THE DOSSIER WAS JUST
MADE UP GARBAGE, AND THE SUB
SOURCE TOLD THE NORTHBOUND
AGENTS THAT AND YET JAMES COMEY
AND ANDREW MCCABE KEPT ON
PUSHING FORWARD RENEWING WARRANT
S TO SPY ON CARTER PAGE
AND YOUR REACTION TO WHAT WE
KNOW NOW AN WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
HEAR FROM JOHN DURHAM AND WILL
THERE BE INDICTMENTS, SIR?
>> WELL I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE EXPECT IN DYE INDICTMENTS
I KNOW I DO EXPECT BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE WE’VE SEEN.
LINDSEY GRAHAM DID A GOOD JOB IN
GETTING THAT OUT.
WE KNOW THEY NOT ONLY KNEW THERE
WASN’T A CASE BUT THEY CONTINUED
TO INVESTIGATE AND SPY AND YES I
USE THE WORD "SPY" ON TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OFFICIALS, AND ACTUALLY
, EVEN DOING THINGS WHEN
THIS PRESIDENT WAS SWORN IN, AND
AFTER THAT, AND DOING IT IN AN
INAPPROPRIATE MANNER.
YOU’RE GOING TO SEE A COUPLE OF
OTHER DOCUMENTS COME OUT IN THE
COMING DAYS THAT WILL
SUGGEST THAT NOT ONLY WAS THE
CAMPAIGN SPIED ON, BUT THE
FBI DID NOT ACT APPROPRIATE
LY AS THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING.
IT’S ALL STARTING TO COME TO
UNRAVEL AND I TELL YOU IT’S TIME
THAT PEOPLE GO TO JAIL AND
PEOPLE ARE INDICTED.
MARIA: IT’S JUST UNBELIEVABLE
THAT FOR THREE YEARS, THIS
PRESIDENT WAS INVESTIGATED
AND INVESTIGATED AGAIN OVER
SOMETHING THAT WASN’T EVEN TRUE
AND THE ENTIRE COUNTRY WAS UP IN
ARMS ABOUT COLLUSION.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, I DON’T HEAR
ANYTHING ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE ABOUT THIS WRONGDOING,
WHICH IS JUST STUNNING TO ME.
>> WELL IT IS STUNNING AND HERE
IS THE INTERESTING THING IS IT’S
NOT ONLY THAT IT WASN’T TRUE.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY KNEW IT
WASN’T TRUE AND WHEN YOU KNOW
SOMETHING IS NOT TRUE AND YOU
CONTINUE THE INVESTIGATION,
THAT’S COLLUSION.
THAT’S THE KIND OF THING WE MUST
STOP AND THAT’S WHERE WE NEED TO
HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
MARIA: MARK IT’S GREAT TO HAVE
YOU THIS MORNING PLEASE COME